[Music]
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest you see an
enchanted forest yes it was a magical
place but something went wrong since
then no one can get in or out that was
epic
[Music]
what would I do without you you'll
always have me
how's Elsa seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa there's this voice voice what
does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers I'm
going with you
Anna no excuse me I climbed the North
Mountain survived a frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming that's normal
where are we how did you get in the
force the mist parted for has impossible
where did you learn magic
[Music]
you can follow me in the fire
then don't run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you she
may lose herself
protect arendelle at all cost
[Music]
I believe in you Elsa more than anyone
or anything
quick question is the whole putting up
immortal games are gonna be a regular
thing
you